this video is sponsored by
kefs Neil was 46 when it was discovered
that there was a malformation in his
brain although this was on the face of
it terrible news sometimes terrible news
presented at the right time becomes good
news sometimes it doesn't it wasn't
quite clear yet what this was the
malformation was discovered after Neil
had a seizure while at work he was a
professor of philosophy at New York
University while teaching his course
pessimism Despair and hope suddenly his
head tilted up to the side his eyes
rolled back his mouth opened like it was
being pulled by a string and then he
collapsed backwards the good news was
this didn't kill him and it allowed the
arterial venous malformation in his
brain to be discovered before it did at
the hospital the doctors were able to
embolize the brain hemorrhage that had
caused the seizure which occurred
because of the Mal formation the
embolization filled the abnormal
connections between his arteries and
veins and prevented oxygenated blood
from circulating throughout his brain
even better news the malformation was
located close enough to Neil's skull
where it could be accessed and removed
completely but there was a big catch the
Mal formation was located in Neil's
frontal lobe the area of the brain
responsible for things like the way you
think problem solve and engage with
language and so one of the consequences
of removing this piece of his brain was
that it would likely affect his ability
to think abstractly to reason assess and
comprehend theoretical and complex ideas
of course this was a central requirement
for his work as a philosopher and a
fundamental part of his identity he
could of course choose to not have the
surgery and continue on as he was but
without the surgery Neil risked having
another brain hemorrhage that could kill
[Music]
him Neil had dedicated nearly his whole
life to philosophy starting as a young
boy he spent much of his time reading
and engaging in philosophical questions
this was at least partly motivated by
his circumstances at the time at just 8
years old he experienced the intensity
of death and loss as he watched his
older brother pass away from acute myoid
leukemia this left Neil an only child
not long after his parents divorced some
fair weather marriages only become a
parent when the first real storm
hits Neil's father was a hotel
consultant who traveled and moved around
a lot often bringing Neil with him
between the early death of his brother
the ending of his parents' marriage the
isolation inherent to traveling and
moving around as an only child and the
wide spread exposure to many different
cultures places and aspects of humanity
particularly the problems and suffering
that pervade it all compelled Neil more
and more toward philosophy toward
seeking answers and
understandings throughout adolesence
Neil particularly found himself
compelled toward philosophical pessimism
he would study and read The Works of
philosophers like Fodor dovi Arthur
schopenhauer Lev shesto Emil Chon Peter
wessell zapa and many others in
adulthood he would become a professor of
philosophy at several major universities
and author six books a couple of which
became successful both in and outside of
the intellectual Community he quickly
became a well-respected writer and
philosopher particularly renowned for
his dark nihilistic yet beautiful
writing style Neil's work often
challenged accepted and acceptable
viewpoints of humanity and existence it
viscerally embodied the feelings of
alienation bleakness and absurdity often
both destroying and repairing the reader
with the same line it wasn't that Neil
wanted to be pessimistic he just wanted
and needed to be honest and well-
defined with himself as well as the
world and in doing so he simply found
himself with this sort of pessimistic
View and Sensibility the desire was
truth and honesty at any cost not
bleakness or pessimism but truth and
honesty at any cost includes bleakness
and
pessimism now Neil was left with the
following two options undergo the
surgery and likely no longer be able to
meaningfully engage in philosophy or not
undergo the surgery and risk dying from
from another brain hemorrhage it wasn't
quite that simple of course the odds of
experiencing another brain hemorrhage
that could kill him were around 60% the
odds of the surgery killing him were
around 10% so there were still some
elements of convoluted just in terms of
survival also it wasn't as if the
surgery was going to make him feel or
seem like a dramatically different
person the doctors believed that because
of the location and condition of the Mal
formation it would most likely just
affect his abstract thinking reasoning
and comprehension of complex ideas
for many this choice would be obvious
for Neil it wasn't for his girlfriend
Maya however it was the surgery you have
to get the surgery is this seriously
even a question she said to Neil while
they sat on the couch after returning
home from the hospital Neil just sat
there rubbing his chin his eyes bounced
back and forth to her off the floor I
don't know I have to think Neil said
think that's your problem you
intellectualize everything and now
you're considering letting yourself die
over the prospect of not being able to
intellectualize everything you've spent
your whole life asking questions and
thinking abstractly about everything but
what has that gotten you are you better
off than before you started or if you
never had at all have you found anything
other than answers you either can't know
or would have been better off not
knowing depends on what you mean by
better off Neil
answered see that's what I mean
everything doesn't need to be so
complicated but everything is Neil
interjected everything is what you see
it as maybe having a chance to see life
without it always having to be condensed
into precise reasons or abstracted into
some Theory won't be such a bad thing
Neil sat silently staring Forward
Thinking Maya began to
cry a couple days went by one of Neil's
close friends and colleagues George who
was also a professor of philosophy at
NYU stop by Neil's house to see how he
was doing almost to a fault George was
an extremely straightforward W no
kind of guy much like Neil at
some point in their conversation after
explaining Everything Neil asked George
for his thoughts about the
situation well wouldn't you be dead
anyway if you got the surgery and it
took from you what makes you who you are
George said how could you give up the
ability to think and understand the
truth of things the same way you always
have to be able to question things with
that level of granularity you've
dedicated your life to to potentially
not even care about contemplating things
it's like returning to the starting
point of philosophy and not even
choosing to pick up the first book it's
like trading everything you've worked
for a deep understanding of existence
for ignorance is that what you want
George concluded Neil nodded at George
as he exhaled with his lips clenched
that was something he probably would
have told somebody else in his position
but actually being in a position is a
lot different than telling someone what
you would do if you
were around a week later Neil's father
came to visit him a very stoic pragmatic
individual
at some point in their conversation
after explaining everything an Neil
asked him for his thoughts H his father
said I've always respected what you do
you know that but I've never fully
understood it to be honest I've lived my
whole life without asking any of these
sorts of what do you call them
metaphysical questions and I've been
fine you know what they say right
ignorance is bliss Neil looked at his
father his eyes seemed to widen a bit as
he
did but his father continued
at the same time there are things in my
life that I would sacrifice Bliss for
that I wouldn't want to live without I
guess you have to ask yourself what's
that for you is philosophy more
dangerous than it's worth here or is it
worth the
risk Neil spent the rest of the week
thinking back and forth back and forth
back and
forth the next Monday he had a follow-up
appointment with the neurologist he sat
across from them in their office looking
down so
the doctor said have we decided are we
moving forward with the surgery Neil
looked up and breathed in
deeply yes I've decided he said
[Music]
confidently this video was sponsored by
keeps as many as 85% of men will
experience some sort of notable hair
loss by the age of 50 this is nothing to
be ashamed of of course but it's also
nothing that we need to freely accept if
we don't want to for some hair loss is
what it is but for many others of us who
value and prefer having our hair as long
as we reasonably can losing it can be a
very upsetting experience keeps is an
online subscription service that
provides FDA approved treatments and
products that can help prevent hair loss
and promote hair growth making it so
that you don't have to freely accept
your genes or circumstances and can
continue to live with the feature of
your identity that you value according
to clinical studies treatments offered
by keeps are 90% effective at treating
hair loss and can increase hair growth
by up to 35% most keeps customers notice
results within just 6 months after
starting their treatment without ever
having to leave the comfort of your home
keeps delivers treatment to your door at
a price typically half the cost of going
to a pharmacy via online consultation
with the licensed medical provider keeps
also ensures that treatment and delivery
plans actually make sense for you and
your unique needs keeps has helped
nearly 1 million men keep their hair and
has over an astounding 4,500 f-star
reviews whether you're looking to
stimulate hair growth be proactive and
prevent hair loss or just take better
care of your hair in general keeps is
the perfect solution for a special offer
to get started go to keeps.com pursuit
of Wonder or click the link in the
description that's keeps.com SLP pursuit
of Wonder and of course as always thank
you so much for watching in general and
see you next
video
[Music]